[Music]
in suspect at large news large large
submitted by Alex loves JK news thank
you
a 900-pound drug suspect had to have a
hole cut in his house to get him the
court nine hundred pounds the human body
is [ __ ] amazing is he some moment
still alive Halsey Samoan he might still
be like a buff looking dude like I don't
know his height and I don't know isn't
wise nine hundred pounds of why he
sounds like he's a white guy cuz his
name is Kenneth Hicks he's 48 years old
from Virginia and so he was involved in
victory thanks shits down a hundred
pounds you know I know how to use a
bathroom at that point what dude you
might break the toilet you can't have a
regular one that toy is gonna break I
just saw drugs these cells it through
his window you know so I wanted to know
I did in his crease he just has the
[ __ ] four set the longed-for Sam
Hiromi so all they say about like why
he's being charged that he pled guilty
in a cocaine conspiracy case not doing
coke though for sure that's the most it
says huh that's it could be anything
than selling drugs should have been
doing some coke I'm sure he's not
delivering any definitely wasn't using
it or delivery delivery
there's always making it either that'd
your pounce on the booze you probably
had like a booth like a you know like
those drive up drive-through coffee
dream okay I can't imagine what it feels
like being nine hundred pounds because
even being 260 pounds felt terrible so
if you're if you're 900 like what the
[ __ ] does that feel like
probably just terrible from 290 up to
900 like it's the same like what role
did he play in a cocaine conspiracy
that's what I want to know was he just
like a middleman telling you where to
get it he was you're sitting there are
people just like stinking coke into his
cracks yeah and he'd even know
what can take you the human bush oh you
know what in this other article it says
court papers show that the alleged
conspiracy to distribute and possess
with the intent to distribute more than
a pound of cocaine took place from 2013
to 2017 destroy three of seven people
have been charged in this conspiracy I
bet you he can [ __ ] keister a pound of
cocaine
maybe people come to him and he divides
it up to the dealers and [ __ ] maybe he's
one of those guys this keister only meme
in your butt no but yeah get your
keister out of here
oh I thought okay yeah so they had to
cut a hold on the side of his home to
get him out that was my favorite part
during daytime talk shows remember when
there's like like the fat yep episode
I'm too fat yeah [ __ ] bust out the
wake up time he said poor the wall and
it get a forklift and put him on the
[ __ ] forklift that's when they were
showing the guys breakfast now I can't
remember exactly what it was but it was
something along the lines of like a
stack of pancakes this big I know there
was at least like rashers of bacon and
and then there was that should be
considered abuse if you're if you're at
like what's the word enabling yeah she
was making all the food friends so he
was getting food made for him yet the
mom but you know you can't like
dramatically decrease their calorie Oh
cuz he'll just die of starvation yeah
sorry you got to wean it off even dogs
same thing if they're obese they're
overweight you have to wean them off so
that stack just has to like increment
well same thing with certain drug addict
oh yeah yeah so what they did is they
brace the structure of the home and they
removed orientation they removed trees
to clear the pad and then mechanically
lifted him out down a thousand-year old
oak tree huh just bring him out it's in
that crazy
FBI US Marshals local ambulance firing
emergency personnel well I wasn't
away I bet you most of them they're like
what there's a 900-pound [ __ ] coke
dealer we're just like other day you
probably smelled really bad dude they
didn't mention that like the first court
appearance was through a video link
that's so funny
Oh make it there so he asked for help to
make the latest hearing in person and
then they told him that if he pled
guilty then he could be taken to a
hospital instead of a jail so that's
what I ended up doing you know for a
punishment they should just put him on a
diet I bet you that already be torture
friend dude someone was cooking for him
and they should jail that person too
probably the mom mom or dad cuz as you
probably need to like how do you word
this guy so Co welfare oh yeah anyway
that's right you probably started
selling coke so you could eat more maybe
use like I'm gonna have non-stop foods
these on disability for sure this crazy
to think that like what sentence could
you give him that's like a worst prison
and what he's living dan hyee
that's crazy like what's worse like this
sounds like could be an improvement like
now you'll be in a jail and people make
sure you have what you need to stay
alive what kind of mattress brand is eat
Russell Simmons Sealy service Springer's
via casper guy aloe guy when you're that
fat do you sit down or lay down all day
are you just maybe default existed I
feel like you want to be able to because
of all the pressure on his chest this
wouldn't it compress your spine too much
well maybe on an angle yeah cuz we're
sure the mattress Trent he has has to be
a haystack because there's nothing else
he's a [ __ ] human being bag
I one of my dreams is to see like real
fat people in real life look it's like I
already see them but like I'm always
trying to beat the last level I'm like
fat they're probably like 300 pounds
they're probably likes for like I don't
never seen a 900 slike this guy come
right now really and then I watch I want
to watch it go down like I want to be
the neighbor like I'm there walking my
dogs and then they're busting down the
door like the whole wall and in there
for 15 good you just go to Hawaiian
Gardens has all you can eat KFC you will
find them there go to [ __ ] in any Golden
Corral no but what he wants to see I've
seen them though well I need to be cut
out of there I want to see that you
can't you think I don't know why they
took away the freakshow from the circus
because cuz they're humans to Joe but
they're like really that's different
this is getting dangerous here why I
mean it's you're telling me that if you
saw a 900-pound person on a forklift you
wouldn't go oh my god yes I think all of
us we're not making it a dream goal what
did you already thinking I don't Joe you
say my mind I want to know what your
secrets I just to me like I like I like
watching human achievements oh that
isn't just when I look at that I'm like
how is that not achievement but it's
like the the possibilities and limits to
human capability right because I'm just
like that's insane how resilient the
human body is yeah that's true it's that
[ __ ] fat and it survived I know you
know we saw the bus yeah imagine they
had like a body of a person like Oh like
just flesh you can see why is that bad
it's not bad now that you've explained
it for scientific purposes there's we
did see a human body that's what I mean
there's a show on Netflix were they were
they're showing how unhealthy it is to
be like morbidly
biess and as they're talking about it in
between the sets there they're cutting
open a body of a morbidly open to show
you the effects of what it is to be fat
like this person had like just fat all
around there like important organs it
was disgusting good is pretty crazy like
how thick the fat layer is yeah because
I mean I understand the having sympathy
for the person that's like it's like
it's like dur Natick right like I that
part is like I get it it's it's it's
logical cuz humans - yeah I get it
but also there's the other part of me
that's just like I like things that are
just really different
well you curiosity yeah I can't act like
it doesn't exist like I want to see it I
want to see it in real life you know
like and I think a lot of other people
do too
I'm not gonna pretend it doesn't exist
like they're just normal humans yeah I
mean like inside but outside me you know
me like that's different
no that's why they watch this show I'm a
[ __ ] spectacle but you know what I
mean like that's cuz a lot of people are
afraid to be themselves that'd be so
funny if you walk into a human circus
thing and that bat person looks at you
and says why aren't you in here like
this to you like have you seen like the
world smallest person like on TV it's
like an Indian lady it's just like a
baby oh yeah she's really small it's
like a growth defect thing yeah so she's
kind of her proportions or it does sound
like that what yeah you're right people
do want to see it that's like I'm gonna
go the discrepancies people don't want
to be seen seeing them I would
understand if it was like they're there
and you could have a conversation with
them you're not watching
I'm curious that's why the the freakshow
is gone because nobody wants to go like
as a community and no one sees them as
people in it yeah oh there's a freak
show in Venice
the furry man is there you know the guy
here yeah yeah yeah I'm not the same one
that the daughter got engaged recently I
thought what news reports about he's
done but he's like nah I don't if he's
Mexican but he's like like bacon Cup
I mean they have laser hair removal now
so they could get rid of that thing well
that's true easily I feel like they're
like x-men you know they have like
special powers and it's like a gift but
it's also a curse you know I don't know
about the the the super obese one I
don't know about that I guess the gift
is you could eat a lot ton and stay
alive so yeah I guess so because that's
like that you can be a skinny guy and
just eat too much meat and get colon
cancer and totally physically fit yeah
so that there's a definitely something
awesome about a guy that got that big
yeah and he's breathing fine and dealing
drugs
oh and he's living yeah and then we're
all feeling sorry for him and he's like
yo I like to eat it'd be even more
respectable if that guy didn't he wasn't
even on disability like he was making
his home like I love you like yo holy
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]